want to shout out to all the ladies that
watch I have your back so don't worry oh
no
doctors
let me tell you something this [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] I posted on the Goddamn
point of this thing I post a [ __ ]
clip from this show on my Instagram
talking about this [ __ ] Okay
look dude okay you know what let's just
[ __ ] take it back a little bit all
right so I said I was brought up a buddy
of mine that said he got a vasectomy and
I said I don't know if I would get a
vasectomy and then this [ __ ]
chimes in with his [ __ ] white night
[ __ ] dude always he's ha he's not even
white I'm here for you ladies
dude he came in there with a Kamala hair
shirt
I will advocate for you
while these two
what I said was I wouldn't get a
vasectomy and now this guy's like well
it's not natural for the girl to take a
pill and this and that and it [ __ ] up
their bodies
Khan is not natural pull it out it's a
natural man you're supposed to split
inside yeah and now I'm [ __ ] now I'm
now I'm the [ __ ] on the thing
that was like oh Chris is perpetuated
I'm infatuated [ __ ] oh I am
I care if you're gonna get me in more
trouble dude sorry dude I don't know
what I said but I I don't know what I
said look at this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] baby Eric that [ __ ]
was so sexy
really then [ __ ] them ah yeah I'd say
can I get a win can I get a win look at
this hold on go up go up look at these
comments Eric has some dollars just wait
until y'all have daughter she doesn't
have I I dude you think the Red River
emotions are crazy
they're acting like I said every woman
on the planet should be on birth control
dude I don't even I don't even give a
[ __ ] if you're a birth control or not
bro I pull out if I want man I'm not one
of those guys that's like Mom but it
feels too good dude I pull out them way
back dude I'm in the other room when I I
go baby give me a second I go I make a
sandwich
I'm not off I mean this [ __ ] you get
in the car you're gonna drive you're
gonna Coffee Bean
can I get four shots can I can I get
four shots of
espresso and
that's amazing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey hey
I love people that take all this stuff
serious you're so correct man oh man I
got a message from someone too I sent it
to Chris it was just so funny I
unfollowed Chris
I bet I'm better at pulling out than you
are